- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is get some practice identifying
some transformations.
And the transformations
we're gonna look at
are things like rotations
where you are spinning
something around a point.
We're gonna look at translations,
where you're shifting all
the points of a figure.
We're gonna look at reflection,
where you flip a figure
over some type of a line.
And we'll look at dilations,
where you're essentially
going to either shrink
or expand some type of a figure.
So with that out of the way,
let's think about this question.
What single transformation was applied
to triangle A to get triangle B?
So it looks like triangle
A and triangle B,
they're the same size,
and what's really
happened is that every one
of these points has been shifted.
Or another way I could say it,
they have all been translated
a little bit to the right and up.
And so, right like this,
they have all been translated.
So this right over here
is clearly a translation.
Let's do another example.
What single transformation was applied
to triangle A to get to triangle B?
So if I look at these diagrams,
this point seems to
correspond with that one.
This one corresponds with that one.
So it doesn't look like
a straight translation
because they would have been
translated in different ways,
so it's definitely not
a straight translation.
Let's think about it.
Looks like there might be a rotation here.
So maybe it looks like
that point went over there.
That point went over there.
This point went over here,
and so we could be rotating around
some point right about here.
And if you rotate around that point,
you could get to a situation
that looks like a triangle B.
And I don't know the exact point
that we're rotating around,
but this looks pretty clear,
like a rotation.
Let's do another example.
What single transformation was applied
to quadrilateral A to
get to quadrilateral B?
So let's see, it looks like
this point corresponds to that point.
And then this point
corresponds to that point,
and that point corresponds to that point,
so they actually look like
reflections of each other.
If you were to imagine
some type of a mirror
right over here, they're
actually mirror images.
This got flipped over the line,
that got flipped over the line,
and that got flipped over the line.
So it's pretty clear that this right
over here is a reflection.
All right, let's do one more of these.
What single transformation was applied
to quadrilateral A to
get to quadrilateral B?
All right, so this looks like,
so quadrilateral B is clearly bigger.
So this is a non-rigid transformation.
The distance between corresponding points
looks like it has increased.
Now you might be saying, well,
wouldn't that be, it looks like
if you're making something
bigger or smaller,
that looks like a dilation.
But it looks like this
has been moved as well.
Has it been translated?
And the key here to realize is around,
what is your center of dilation?
So for example, if your
center of dilation is,
let's say, right over here,
then all of these things are
gonna be stretched that way.
And so this point might go to there,
that point might go over there,
this point might go over here,
and then that point might go over here.
So this is definitely a dilation,
where you are, your center where
everything is expanding from,
is just outside of our trapezoid A.